tuve sus disparos mi hermana que hizo
así así como que abrazar y se cayó y
cayó la cabecita sede para acá bueno yo
le digo nos haría me escuchas yo le digo
te acaricia la cara si me escucha
defender el pozo con el que su familia
regaba los cultivos de café le costó la
vida a la lideresa indígena me sacan a
zaira calambás ese mismo agua la usaban
grupos armados para irrigar cultivos
ilícitos de coca su sentencia de muerte
entre páramos atravesado por el río
piendamó está el resguardo misak de
guambía pero velasco su gobernador
explica los motivos del incremento de la
violencia líderes sociales que tienen
que ver con primero pues con la puesta
en marcha de las agendas de los
territorios con las agendas de de
cumplimiento del acuerdo de paz y en
especial con los incumplimientos
históricos de que ha hecho el gobierno
desde la firma de los acuerdos de paz en
2016 1260 líderes sociales han sido
asesinados en colombia según la onic
indepaz en el cauca el 59 por ciento de
los fallecidos eran indígenas las
poblaciones étnicas cada vez más
están siendo desplazadas en nuestros
últimos cinco años la incrementación del
conflicto armado por diversos actores
sea la del estado la de la guerrilla y
otros actores no identificados pues se
están concentrando en inmediaciones o
dentro en los territorios indígenas o
campesinos la recuperación pacífica del
territorio ancestral es su forma de
resistencia de la estrechez de tierra
debido al incumplimiento de la reforma
rural integral y el fondo de tierras
destinadas a su reparación con tan sólo
el 33 por ciento implementado vamos a
hacer la reforma agraria desde los
territorios entonces para que nuestros
jóvenes no se caigan por ejemplo los
jóvenes han ido a raspar coca
a procesar coca bueno por falta
oportunidades en el conflicto armado
sigue haciendo mella en la juventud del
campo colombiano luz dary maestra y
secretaria del resguardo habla de
reclutamiento no hay como ese apoyo en
la parte agraria y por lo mismo pues los
jóvenes nuestras mujeres pues buscan
otras otras otras formas de resistir y
es ahí donde donde pues se están estaba
bien el conflicto armado bien en grupos
armados pues que les prometen o les
dicen que por aquí es el camino y se los
van llevando la paz desde la cosmovisión
de los indígenas pasa por el respeto a
la vida y la tierra algo todavía lejano
en colombia